hey guys my name is Jess today is the
nineteenth of January and here's what
matters in game mark stop has revealed
the first details of the next Xbox one
system update here's what's coming this
month's update which is available now
for preview program members will focus
on social features you'll now be able to
see who we've been a party before
joining it and access in you gamerscore
leaderboard menu in the achievement
section of your profile that also
includes info about who increased their
gamerscore the most over the last 30
days which should satisfy the super
competitive among you on top of that the
update will let you rearrange homescreen
pins and launch said pins when you're
offline microsoft hasn't provided a
public release date as yet but
insinuated that it's likely to come out
in February you can check out the full
list of tweaks and changes arriving in
the update by heading to our story on
gamespot in adorable new today Okajima
and playstation 4 lead architect mark
Cerny are teaming up and heading on a
world tour looking for the world's best
technologies mark cerny joined twitter
today just to post up a picture of
himself and the veteran game designer
with the caption spending the next ten
days with this guy according to a tweet
from Kojima Productions producer
kenichiro in mizzou me the Paris setting
out on a quote high end technology tour
for the next 10 days rajma tweeted a
similar picture which aside from
perfectly exhibiting the body language
of what it's like to take a picture next
to someone you probably don't know super
well echo Bernie's sentiment and called
the trip a world tour the reason for the
trip is currently unknown but if you
guys want to hypothesize about that or
send me a good ship name that combines
kojima and sunny I'm all ears Marcus oft
has confirmed that rise of the tomb
Raider's upcoming expansion Baba Yaga
Temple of the which will be arriving on
Xbox one come January 26 the story
expansion is slated to contain hours of
gameplay featuring new and
needs a new tune with brand new puzzles
to stump you from anywhere between five
minutes to half an hour and it's set to
culminate in a showdown with a new big
fad plus there will also be a new outfit
and bow so yay Lara it's currently
unclear whether the expansion will also
land on xbox 360 all the pc version
which is due out on the twenty-eighth of
january the temple of the which is
included with rise of the Tomb Raider
$30 DLC pass but pricing for this
individual expansion has not been
released as yet the game's first DLC
endurance mode came out at the end of
last year and another expansion called
Colts darkness awaken is true out later
this year I'm no down in that comment
section if you're pleased with the xbox
one system update or if you were hoping
for something different you can add a
game spot where we've got a brand new
division trailer and news on batman
arkham knight dlc that is everything i
have for you today as always let me know
what you thought of today's stories and
i will catch you again tomorrow